mais nous sommes en ce moment
effectivement au quartier camp bay au
vauclin à quelques mètres du bourg de
cette commune sous les 11 hectares de
monsieur breton joël breton
un éleveur qui subit de très très
grosses pattes phénomène récurrent sur
son terrain ici en permanence ses
moutons sont attaqués par des chiens
monsieur boillon que s'est il passé
exactement la nuit dernière ben tu joues
attaquez pas aux chiens mondialisation
mécanicien personnel guy et ses maladies
chiens et puis j'ai un léopard vacances
il incarne et nous cache tout on nous
toutes les mamans esclave bahamas ont
bouclé ce club ses moutons bain - radim
animaux
la semaine dernière map et 16 mai jeudi
à marrakech 4è me koubbi
les 16 qui blessée à moto
on va constater que c'est chiant rester
vigilant pas protégés alors elle songe à
déposer plainte
l'ajout d'amis c'est fini on en est même
venu
merci beaucoup monsieur bré dont donc
voilà le point ici au quartier camp bay
à au vauclin vous avez donc compris que
c'est un agriculteur
excédé il en a vraiment marre de ces
différentes attaques de chiens et le
plus le plus important à signaler tout
de même que c'est un phénomène en
recrudescence sur la martinique car tout
récemment au niveau de ducos dans le sud
de la martinique
les éleveurs ont subi aussi de
nombreuses pertes